this is a production of cornell
university
but yeah we're talking about hydrogen
frank
hydrotech
i used to love my hydrogen i i actually
i think at one point i might have three
of them to keep one running i think we
still do i think we still do but they
don't run you know the thing that's
funny about that before we get started
and you know for those that listen and
if you start the podcast here carl um
this was back when we didn't have as
many options you know rick remembers
when you had one option
right now you got we talked about this
with rock and lawns last week they got
15 options
right but so back in the day this was so
innovative and you know there was good
research that it was beneficial because
of the sort of explosion that happened
which was ideal because we were just
sand top dressing and we were building
up this interface between the native
soils and the sands back then and and if
you didn't blow the stupid stuff back up
it was really ideal uh for that
particular problem see we're gonna have
a ball today carl yeah it's gonna be a
fun one uh thanks everyone for joining
this is week seven the cornell turf show
uh episode 15 and our guest today we've
already been chatting a little bit is a
former superintendent rick slattery uh
you guys will know him from his work at
locust hill country club who hosted an
opg
tournament for many years uh rick's a
good friend of ours we we still work on
projects research projects with frank uh
or with rick most notably our bmp
project with the rit team we'll talk
about that today
um but as always we'll get started frank
with you um you know i had some motion
sickness on an airplane last week and
and maybe it's not the airplane maybe
it's the weather you know this weather
roller coaster that we're on has given
me the the headaches and and the case of
the throw ups uh yeah
what we're saying
well i know first hand carl
it's always it's always fun traveling
with you you're my man i mean i'm
my i have had people call me a camel
the way i travel and and so i'm uh it's
been really great traveling with you hey
welcome everybody to the show uh we're
really excited to have uh rick slattery
my my long time pal now uh we've been
chatting for years about this but let's
get started with the you know everybody
who's working hard right everybody's
working hard getting started and there's
just nothing like good dog pictures to
get them started and and really for one
of the topics we're going to chat about
with rick today uh you know people
firing up those systems here we are down
in the carolinas and and we used to have
a dog around uh uh josh fontaine's dog
luna used to love to do this chase after
the sprinkler heads this is a unique
trait uh i would say for uh golf course
people everywhere and uh one of the
things i want to remind you of is
there's a lot of other sadness about
charging up this irrigation system
as phil uh mentions there and just one
more reminder carl before we get to the
tip of the day uh in a couple of weeks
we will not be live here we will be out
at the links of greystone with golf
course superintendent tim hahn and the
gcsa ny doing one of our walk-in talks
uh and it will be a lively discussion
about all things managing early spring
golf courses in the rochester area but
also a lot of bmp stuff as you can see
there's lots of water
on this golf course so you'll know we'll
be yakking about bmp so carl let's where
are we today on the tip
yeah so so our guest today rick some of
you may have heard podcasts in the past
on your podcast frank talking about
uh rick's use of bent grass on his golf
courses and and taking this long-term
approach trying to get the newest
varieties
uh improving the competition out there
to use less resources and so actually we
looked at some data the last couple
years we actually simulated a fairway
management program for dollar spot
and we're going to have this document
coming out here soon with the new york
golf course foundation
uh if you get to that slide there frank
basically this is a graph uh the blue
line is the dollar spot index the smith
current dollar spot index for one year
in ithaca new york back in 2020 and
we've got a couple thresholds there so
in the model a 20 threshold is when they
say you will typically see dollar spot
on uh susceptible turf
that 40 threshold is when you introduce
new varieties dollar spot resistant
varieties
that's when you'll see
dollar spot happen and i've got these
icons up here on the top and these
represent
three different management programs so
the black dots is a typical preventative
program every 21 days you would apply a
fungicide
to reduce dollar spot incidents
the green uh squares are a model based
approach if you still have susceptible
varieties but if you use this data from
the smith currents model that 20
threshold you only treat when you're
above that threshold
and then there's the the red triangles
you notice only two of them on there
this is if you both use the model and
you have resistant fan craft varieties
with now that ups your threshold to 40
you'll notice there's only two red
triangles on here right so in this
specific year you would have only
treated two times compared to the
preventative approach which was seven
times um so we did this for multiple
different years and we put together a
table here a bunch of things going
around but if you if we draw your
attention to that five year total this
is the number of uh fungicide
applications you would have made
under these three different management
approaches for dollar spot and you can
see up there in the top i think in new
york if you use that preventative
approach every 21 days you would have
applied 35 applications over five years
if you have resistant varieties and use
the model
you would have applied only 17 times so
you would have cut your applications in
half
we translate this into dollar amounts
too so you can see you're saving forty
five thousand dollars if you've
transitioned to those resistant
varieties if you're using that data
and this is some of the stuff that that
we worked out we didn't just do it for
ithaca we did it from millbrook new york
an area down in hudson valley as well
so kind of illustrating here the the
real life value you can get from
reducing your fungicide use by employing
uh not only a data driven approach but
the latest turfgrass varieties
carl and so
the perfect
segue is
what do the models currently say i mean
if you look at your chart here
it looks like the first application at
least in 2020 would have been right
around memorial day and the other thing
i want to draw your attention to
uh that you had on this first slide is
improve the competition right seating
with the newest variety so this is so
exciting to see this translate into real
dollar amounts
and again
we're talking early spring here and
we're going to talk about the weather in
a second but clearly we're not anywhere
near uh dollar spot issues and again
when you're talking about large areas
like fairways we want to be really
careful so yeah carl here we go again
with the roller coaster right up and
down and up and then we were up almost
to record highs uh at least in the
ithaca area
over the weekend and now we're well uh
below average not near the record men
but pretty close so the roller coaster
continues
the departure from normal last week
indicated that if you were east of new
york state uh pretty much hudson valley
east you were [ __ ] below normal and
essentially west you were a little bit
above normal with buffalo and and out
western new york western pa coming in at
the warmest now this didn't translate
still very much to to degree days the
the majority of the region was still
getting into 20 to 30 base 50 growing
degree day so not a big advancement you
got to go pretty far south uh into into
delmarva the dmv and and before you
start to see even 70 to 80 base 50
growing degree days
and it doesn't look like this is going
to change very much at least we might
see a little uh warm up
initially and then uh cold again coming
forward so again not a big advancement
maybe 20 30 growing degree days from the
rainfall perspective it was a dry week i
think this would be except for a couple
of areas considered to be very dry
and on the what you notice here and this
is what i talked about with rd guytana
this morning our climate guy um you know
basically saying you know you're
starting to see solar radiation really
increase so you know we got less than a
half to a quarter of an inch and most of
the region is starting to see a half to
three quarters of an inch
of evapotranspiration now right so we're
creeping towards that inch of water lost
a week right that magical value we
always used to talk about so we're just
really starting to see uh the impact of
the sun starting to dry things out and
it doesn't look like uh we're going to
see much change in the near term so it
looks like in the near term it's going
to be
right around uh no right around average
might be a little wet up in the northern
part of maine uh the forecast over a
seven
six to ten day period
is calling for a little uh wetter
condition so we'll uh wait to see how
this continues to pan out
now the two in soil temperature again
really tracks that roller coaster air
temperature and you can see that you
know you're in the 40s out in buffalo
and you're in the 60s down in atlantic
city in the middle atlantic city
metropolitan area you're right around
hovering in the 50s and again some of
this is going to be impacted by how wet
uh or dry you are now in the in the area
of predicting what's going on right
let's look at what the gdd tracker is
telling us uh for where we are with the
things we pay attention to on a golf
course so first off uh just yesterday it
looks like we're just coming in in the
new york metropolitan area to the heavy
poa seed flush now this is a base 22
degree
model that was developed for the seed
head flush okay so you see we're early
and now we're starting to move into
by the middle of next week uh the heavy
seed head flush so you're gonna start to
see now how well your seed head
suppressions have done right now what
you want to be careful and one of the
reasons it's good to pay attention to
this because when you get this flush
this is the beginning of the decline of
some annual bluegrass right flowering
is an energy-intensive process we
haven't talked much about this it's an
energy-intensive process for the poa
that's why suppressing it is good
because data shows rooting and energy
storage
increases so number one it's important
to see that number two if you got a lot
and your seed head thing failed
i would wait
because to put another pgr because it
could prolong the amount of time that
seed head stays on the stalk right you
sort of want to get it to grow out now
if you missed it you want to get it to
grow out so i would be really careful
about continuing to use a seed head
suppression if you're seeing a bunch of
you know more than 50 seed heads
breaking through
now recently we've been talking about uh
annual bluegrass weevil applications
insecticide use on our golf courses so i
think it's mindful with around
pollinator best management practices to
remind you of potential weeds that could
be flowering so right now uh the gdd
tracker indicates that early and
mid-season winter annuals and perennials
are starting to flower uh and we're not
to the mid-season perennials yet so
early on we're starting to get that
early flowering uh of these seed heads
right of these flowering plants so
you'll want to mow
before an herbicide or any pesticide
insecticide application to get the
flowers off obviously you might be doing
weed control to get rid of the flowers
but either way you don't want to be
applying things when there's flowers in
the turf
because the implica the the the research
shows obviously it's going to be
impacting pollinators so that's
something to keep in mind and the last
thing is you can see with this
particular model in crabgrass
germination how are prolonged we are we
still got till next week till we start
to see any germination so i would say
we're we're a little bit behind and i
think with the forsythias uh flowering
uh that might be a little bit of a
asynchronous now so you want to pay
attention to uh crabgrass germination
especially if you're using pres or you
use an early post program like dimension
that'll knock down those early
germinants and not uh
and give you some pre-emergent control
after that all right we're going to
start the transition to our conversation
today and i pulled a couple of pictures
uh this is from uh a golf course in uh
the mid-atlantic region or maybe even
kentucky i think it is kentucky on the
right was with two fall applications of
polo cure
on the left is untreated
so you know this is the what we talk
about you've heard me talk about
with this particular compound i'm not
saying you know there's none of these
things are a free lunch and it's not
like this isn't going to have some
issues associated with it as those of
you might listen to my the frankly
speaking podcast i just had this
conversation with jim brosnan but
there's no denying when i've seen this
happen on multiple continents that using
it according to the directions uh can
not always but can
produce really uh profound results uh
now the other thing to consider my pal
don cross my old buddy at skokie country
club uh
among one of the old guy groups there
rick like you and i re skokie a number
of years ago into bent grass or
wall-to-wall bent grass playing surfaces
new greens new fairways and it's a
donald ross design and he's got a lot of
these uh cut across bunkers on fairways
where fairway mowers have to turn
intensely there and don's approach is
sod it out if it's starting to get too
much power we're just we're just taking
it out right so another strategy for
getting rid of the poem and rick these
are a couple of pictures you sent me
from uh andy ike uh on the right uh the
seedlings coming up under the cover
uh on his screens there at uh mohawk
valley and a sodded area of bank grass
uh there on the left also uh showing
good uh survival from winter injury and
from snow mold
and so i thought i would bring up a
couple of pieces of data that i got from
bill criser at nebraska
bill a number of years ago and for a
number of years has been studying
desiccation
uh of bank grass turf out in the midwest
when it when they don't get snow they
get a lot of wind it's really cold
and they wake up and their bent grass is
dead a very different situation than us
but nevertheless i want to talk about
what they found here with seeding right
so here you're looking at temperatures
of the year back in 2014
and the quality of seed germination and
you can see uh really quickly that the
green jacket permeable cover
right and even a plastic cover uh is is
or a weed barrier uh is another kind of
cover all of the covers work better than
pigments and doing nothing but by far
the permeable cover seems to be the best
now here is what not seeding into bank
grass looked like uh in the first four
to six weeks
without any uh seating uh in this case
not very much coverage 16 at week six
and here you have with seating a lot of
over you know
in one direction you get really good
coverage within six weeks so the value
of seeding the value of covers and
recovering some of these damaged areas
and i remember talking to rick about
this many years ago on the podcast and
you know you wouldn't associate a
picture of people hand watering for
example somebody who saved a lot of
water but yet when you spend any time
with rick like carl and i
have the pleasure of doing you know this
was one of the ways he avoided running
more water was to go out to be more site
specific now one of the things i do have
to put up with this knucklehead is these
uh taunts i get uh now he's worried that
coal has got sticky stuff on his butt
and when he goes to fenway the umps
angel hernandez with the floating strike
zone
is going to start grabbing cole's butt
to see if there's anything sticky there
so rick as we start to talk uh i i want
to remind you he wrote this great
article in golftham about 12 years ago
now where you wrote on the heels of a
paul azinger
address at a gcsa meeting back then how
you know you felt strongly we must
reduce our dependence on water now the
usga uh has a a number of informations
about this i think everybody in the golf
industry uh is embracing this uh to a
certain extent and certainly there's
lots of technology uh from subsurface
irrigation controllers turf soil sensors
you name it the technology is out there
but deep thoughts from my pal here and
what he wrote was you know one of the
things we better start doing
is proactively addressing how to use
less water and and a simple thing for
everybody to do and i think brick has
talked about this in his wash pad talks
over the years is just to simply you
know measure how much water you're
actually using so rick uh here's the
questions for today the two things i
sort of covered in our 10-minute chat
we'll get to have here
uh what are some of the early season
things you used to like to do
to favor your bent grass and maintain
good plane quality then we'll get to the
water management thing so let me stop
sharing and look at you and so the
podcast people don't have to feel like
they're missing anything um what do you
like
for you know you gotta
pull a golf course
especially when you got there uh you
know you see a lot of pulley got some
bent what are some of these early things
you were thinking about doing
that favored the bank grass uh over the
pope
well i could tell you that
you know i was starting my career in in
1970 so
i was able to uh actually watch what
happened
uh as polis started coming into the golf
courses over a long period of time and
in the early in the 70s we never used to
worry about power too much and
you know i think that's because inputs
were minimal
and as we started adding irrigation
systems and automatic irrigation adding
water
uh the polars just started to take off
on a lot of golf courses a lot of weird
diseases started to pop up and thrack
those things we'd never seen before
and so i really think that if you're
trying to transition from
uh you know power to ben
the place to start really is with water
and reducing your water and using the
least amount possible
and you know that also plays into
playability uh you know keeping the
playing surface firm
and uh the golfers like it uh you know
the drives roll a lot further
um but that's basically where you start
and i think what this winter and this
spring has shown a lot of people at
least to me is number one i think it's i
feel sorry for everybody because it's
kind of testing their patience uh they
had not only a lot of winter kill but
now they've had a cold they got a cold
spring and so they just can't bring it
back quick enough and we're trained
to to try to react and try to fix things
and one of the hardest things for
superintendents to do is to not do
anything at all
and it's not very good to be able to
probably tell your membership that
you're not doing much either so you try
to do something but it's it's been so
slow the recovery but i think what it's
shown
is that i think as climate change
advances
polar is just not going to be
sustainable anymore you're getting these
you when you get these extremes in the
weather uh power just does not react
well to that and if everybody looks at
their greens a lot of the photos we've
seen uh the brent grass is doing fine
and uh if you had a golf course that's
100 bent you're probably not having much
of a problem right now would you start
the water if let's say you know
you know early spring you know i just
made a case like well it's getting dry
for the first time you got some sand
let's take away the guys who aren't
recovering from damage because there's
you know not everybody got hit so
there's a lot of guys growing grass
right now
we're starting to see that shift do you
remember i remember the first time i
talked to you on the phone back when we
actually had to call each other from
offices back in the
mid 90s and i called you up yeah once i
get the 3 million gallons i just shut
the valve off i don't care by august i'm
done with it so what about the other
side of it when you start going if
you're not injured are you in a rush to
get everything fired up talk to me about
that no uh you know if i'm not trying to
bring anything back if i'm in you know
like for the lpga people used to come up
to me and say what do you do to prepare
for the tournament there was usually any
time between the beginning of june and
third week of june they say what do you
do to get prepared for i said nothing
i i used to love dormant turf you know
or semi-derp dormant turf uh if it's not
disease if it's not under stress a
little bit of stress fine in the spring
you see i sometimes would see a little
welt or something during the day but the
night times are so long and so cool
everything would pop back and be looking
fine just by the next day
but i never used to do anything at all
and then uh you know in the spring and i
used to hold off water as long as i
possibly could
until i just absolutely had to i can
remember one time i didn't turn the
irrigation system on to check it until
like a week before the lpga we had a
main line break and i had a guy out
fixing the main line
you know a week before the tournament
because i don't rely on on on irrigation
in the spring i think that really
paul loves the springtime and anything
you can do to weaken it in the spring
is going to be beneficial if you're
trying to promote ben okay okay so one
of the knocks and you know again maybe
we've gotten better at this but one of
the knocks you'd make is well bankrupt
just doesn't get going i mean these
people have been playing up in rochester
for a month rick
it was nice at the end of march honestly
and it's been this up and down and up
you know one day a golf superintendent's
bailing hay on a green
and four days later he's barely shaving
anything because it's been so cold uh
the grass is sitting there
you were getting you were getting ready
for a tournament plus you had country
club play those greens weren't very big
how did the bank grass do under all that
traffic was that an issue early spring
not having power there no
it wasn't never really an issue for me
the the the stuff that didn't look good
was the poem you know that's the stuff
that would look did it would seed out uh
you know things like that but
uh it's the power that would kind of get
weak if the bent wasn't just because
it's not growing doesn't mean it's okay
if it's healthy and it's alive and it's
good and it's it's not in decline
who cares you know just let it sit there
and then when you get the warm a little
bit of a warm temp the bent will push a
little bit push a little bit on that
power
um but uh i never really had a problem
uh with the bend like as you talk about
as as everybody talks about well it
doesn't get going quick enough and all
that
but uh you know like you saw from andy
ike there i mean you saw his his uh his
the results he's having he seeded that
about three weeks ago and and he's got
great new seedlings coming up and
everything like that but i never used to
worry about it i i liked having dormant
turf that means i didn't have you know a
little bit of
the bent grass would react fine
where i started seeing maybe some
problems a little bit with the bent
grasses with the spiking and things like
that when it starts getting a little a
little uh you know a little puffy and
things like that but as soon as i
applied nitrogen to a green i started
losing green speed
and as long as that
that bent's dormant and it's not dead
and it's not struggling i never saw a
problem you know it was it was growing
slower but uh you know i preferred
keeping the keeping the ball for a week
so what about um growth regulators a lot
of what i watched you do was cultural
um we have growth regulators i'm sure
you saw that polar cure slide it
certainly caught my attention
i'm assuming you would have embraced
that particular technology wouldn't you
have yeah
yeah anything to anything to defeat pola
um you know anything to to gain see
sometimes even in when you get these
hybrid golf courses you know you're not
going to get a complete takeover of ben
but
you know what you're trying to do is
you're trying to win the battle and not
the war and if you can gain territory if
you can just gain territory if you can
make that patch of bend just a little
bit bigger because i'll guarantee it the
thing i used to always worry about was
the next time this weather pattern comes
around i'm going to lose that grass
again the grass had died this time next
time we get this in this weather pattern
it's going to die again so you got to do
something to strengthen it and
the thing that the the thing that was
remarkable to me as i went through this
in my career was i really saw i think
paul will adapt it'll adapt to any it
wants to survive it'll adapt to any kind
of environmental conditions or any kind
of management program to put in place
and the polar that i did had didn't see
i didn't worry about seed heads you were
just talking about seed head suppression
the poor i had on the golf course didn't
see i never treated the seeds the first
two or three years i was at local still
my fairway mowers would come in covered
with seed heads
covered with seed heads secede heads
everywhere and
as i started adapting more to the benton
and having the
the low import bent programs those seed
heads started to reduce and and and that
maybe it's the perennial polar that
doesn't seed and i never had a problem i
never treated for seed heads after
probably about five or six years
and uh you know
i just
the poor will adapt so the power that i
had on the golf course when i left
reacted the same as the bent grass the
same as the bench grass i didn't have to
have a different program for it now i
had certain greens
that i had trouble getting a high
percentage of bent in so those did have
to be where we talk about a lot spot
treated yeah there were maybe two or
three greens i went out and i might have
hit him with a little bit of fertilizer
right now you know because i they were
high percentage of polar and i needed
had growing environments bad growing
environments shade
uh one i had a two-tiered green was
facing north that always gave me a
problem um so you know you treat those
greens you do something with those
dreams but you don't do all 18. right
you know that's where you look at you
want to scout your golf course to look
at it you've got two three weak greens
it's okay to go out and maybe have you
if you have to spray him for something
or if you have to put some fertilizer on
him or something but the others that are
strong and healthy and things like that
just stay away from them and and try not
to do have any inputs until you
absolutely have to okay so listen carl
as the reigning new york statement
amateur champ
talking to the 1968
new hampshire state golf champion
what do you want to ask as a golfer when
you see him not doing much in the spring
what do you want to talk to rick about
playability wise
yeah i think and and i'm not going to
ask this question but i think a lot of
members would ask this question rick is
i think they would look at the color of
a golf course and and what i see early
in the season is you see like you know
the rye grass is greening up and you see
the poe still kind of looks bad the
bent's not really green enough and if i
don't see you doing anything as a golfer
i'm like you know well how are you going
to get faster green speeds unless you do
something rick you know i don't see it
green is that going to mean my fairway
lie is different
what did you say early in the season as
you know we saw that spot watering of of
your fairways and you got more bent
grass in there
what did those sort of look like and
then what did they play like early in
the season uh and how could you talk to
your golfers about about those two
things we used to have a tournament
called the locust it was a uh
invitational tournament low handicappers
uh it was about the second week of float
uh
may and uh it was always a struggle
getting ready for it but again uh
dormant turf you know the bent grass
isn't growing too much i could shave the
greens down
uh do whatever you want in the spring
you can beat the crap out of polar in
the spring and you can't kill it
and i'd shave the greens roll them put a
little put a little uh
uh
you know growth regulator down i had
green speeds you know way off the charts
you know early because i didn't have any
growth like i said as soon as i added
fertilizer that's when things started
slowing down i had to struggle to keep
the green speeds up but the thing i
would talk to the members about
is don't look at the color but look at
look at the playability are the greens
rolling true are they quick
you know that kind of thing and and then
i would always point out the new growth
and i think that's the key to a lot of
my thinking when i was a when i was a
superintendent i always look at the new
growth and if i had new growth coming
out i would show that to the members and
explain to them you know you see this
new growth coming out of the sheath and
you know a week or 10 days that's going
to take over the plant but if you
shouldn't be treating anything that's
killing the old growth if the old growth
is dying it's got some disease on it but
the new growth doesn't show it
doesn't show that will problem or
anything like that
then you know leave it alone the new
growth will uh will uh you know take
over pretty soon but
in the spring by not doing anything not
fertilizing not water and i had those
dry
slow
i mean for the tournament i rarely when
i had conditions right i really had to
double cut because when i double cut on
the second cut i never got any never got
any grass and we got very little on the
first cut
and that used to protect me against
rainfall too because let's say in this
time here you don't have the labor to
get out mall and stuff like that so you
don't have to mows off and see
spend time doing other things like
checking your irrigation system and and
you know troubleshooting that and
so you know i think along with all those
things i think communication with your
members and in the in the long run
i don't think they expect
perfectly green conditions in april
so it gives you an opportunity to get in
there and do some things
that might not look so good but as long
as the playability is good and i used to
have members come up to me in greens
committee and they would talk to me and
they'd say just just don't mess up the
greens as long as the greens are rolling
good
you know you're going to be good and
throughout my career i worked it
that's where the money is and that's
what where guys want to focus
and whether you're at a high-end course
or a golf course i worked at center
point country club we had budget 180 000
but we had some of the best cranes in
town because you've got a small amount
of acreage everybody's got enough
fertilizer and enough pesticide and some
sand top dressing and maybe a vertical
machine that you can make those greens
really good and then the rest of the
course they don't really
see as much you know
so concentrate on the greens but dormant
turf in the spring
is very playable turf it's just great
great as long as it doesn't wear out
right as long as it's not wearing out if
that's wearing out then you got to get
in there that's time to get into a
little fur maybe a tenth of a pound or
something get it we're working but
that's worth scouting your golf course
and
and you know keeping a good eye on
things and the trends that are going on
and the weather that's coming up that's
where all that comes into uh in the play
okay words of wisdom
thank you rick good having you here carl
get us out of here yeah rick as always
it's a pleasure chat with you guys uh
thanks everyone for joining tomorrow on
our lawn and grounds
session we'll have kale bigelow from uh
purdue and we'll have an interesting
chat with kale he's he's been a guest on
before so you'll uh you'll enjoy
listening to him again if you've done
that before everyone take care we'll see
you tomorrow
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu